c'est un scoop concédé langues de vip on
s'était tripoter un peu la nuit avec
qatar s'il vous plaît mathieu n'a pas de
gentiment mais là je trouve que c'était
passé parce que tu as demi on a tous des
petits des fonds voilà moi je le jure
bien gérer les petits trucs on a rigolé
passer d'une autre époque
laquelle n'a sûrement jamais on sait
très bien que c'est faux
alors bien entendu si poser des
questions ça va écouter ça franchement
il n'ya pas de radio pas de l'héberger
c'est vrai il restait signera et
attendait mais par quoi je suis resté
sous mais pas qu'arsenal c'est vrai mais
voilà quand vous avez habité ensemble
tous les deux mois il a il habitait chez
vous m'avez dit je vais rester quatre
semaines
ouais non il est resté six mois et j'ai
un bon nom alors alors alors blague à
part ce que lui dit bêtises moi je suis
un show n'était droit et c'est un garçon
très bien élevé très poli très grande et
sachant que dire le week end des 10 et
l'appartement ils sortent sur vos
clinique une assiette dans l'avc n'est
pas pour pouvoir pas qu'il y avait des
choses tout y est passé
mais en attaque sur était là
comment je suis resté six mois et pas
quatre semaines pourquoi parce que
s'accrocher très belle histoire de
allons voir maintenant que vous entendez
très très bien comme ça peut tourner
comme
ça